boa noite a todos
fiquei muito contente como convidada
para participar neste evento porque não
poderia escolher um nome melhor do que
mais a psicologia positiva tentar o
apuramento em alta
de facto muito trabalho nós fazemos tem
a ver com o controle mental e com a
decisão
esse neurociências cognitivas e eu
tivesse que escolher duas palavras eram
exatamente estas aquilo que é mais
importante na vida em termos de
psicologia positiva
são estas duas palavras considerem como
controlar a decisão
posso dar um exemplo o twist na outra
competição isso é muito importante
o ponta de lança com 80 escolher o lado
para onde tirar estar uma interação 22
uma interação social guarda vento tem
que escolher uma trompa prontos a tirar
isso tem que ser seguido uma fração de
segundos e por isso é por vezes nos
surpreendemos como é possível falhar em
autênticos e vir a ser seguida numa
fração de segundos
nós tentamos cuidar de sua saúde e na
doença porque há certas doenças em que
este controle mental está fortemente
perturbada e essa era a letra esquerda
muitas vezes estamos envolvente e
interações de dois doentes somos
interpelados temos que tomar uma decisão
em função dos gestos são me diz se
alguém falar hoje em gestos solidários
para figurar direita
todavia muito antes da gente interpretar
com a intenção do nosso promotor numa
interação social é preciso perceber o
mundo que vivemos interpretá lo e nós
pensamos que esteja assegurado de certas
doenças como o autismo esquizofrenia 6 e
se não é assim uns podem de fato ver o
mundo de uma forma diferente e por isso
vamos seguir
uma forma diferente e portanto eu estava
a receber acho que a imagem de uma aluna
minha ao time d'almeida
gostava de saber o que estão vendo
alguém podem falar que estou ver uma
cara alguém estava em outra coisa e não
há outra coisa quem passa pela zona
branca é um passa tanta mulher ao passo
que estão querendo exemplo só para verem
como nós podemos interpretar um maneira
diferente e o próximo fly de down
querido lembra que já havia sido de joão
pessoa ariane o que estou a ver a minha
esquerda é fácil do lado esquerdo e
direito a mesma faça inverter a toda a
gente conseguiu ver isso não
também não esperava não foi porque as
crianças coisas difíceis a um teste
psicológico
imagine as pretas e brancas e roxas
os psiquiatras atenderam as pessoas para
fazer a interpretação e com base nisso
fazer aumentar a proteção da proximidade
eu só quero dizer com isto é muito antes
de nós cobrarmos as pessoas porque se
deram bem ou mal temos que perceber como
é que elas estão a ver um mundo isso é
muito importante em doenças como
esquizofrenia ou atingem e até outras
como comer precisando é este tem a ver
com um evento que aconteceu segmento é
um esgoto para que o que muitas pessoas
chamaram pseuda cientista
eu como sou cientista achei curioso este
fato porque nessa israel eu vou falar
nomes phelps foi bastante veiculado na
comunicação social entre um americano
estiveram pegar cerca de 450 euros para
assistir às sessões bem tem a ver com
autoajuda é navegável também
neurociência e psicologia positiva
e houve uma manifestação contra esta é
um barco na carta disse foram mamãe
neurocientista que terá organizaram dois
cafés de ciência no perto do local onde
era organizado da organizada gestos fez
o autor sul e vocês poderiam pensar que
eu sei se antes teria enviado a criticar
os seus a cientista que de fato certa
visão é também já participou em eventos
terex curiosamente é eu acho que é que o
grupo faz mudar diz muitas mentirinhas
científicas em dez minutos
todavia eu não posso deixar de achar era
tipo deste livro deus tremendamente
inspiradora e portanto nós não podemos
fazer as coisas preto e branco
nós cientistas tentamos ter um
conhecimento rigoroso das coisas mais
por mês será conseguir a unidade
vencimento e acho que a frase é muito
poderosa porque é uma das mensagens que
eu quero trazer freitas a apresentação
nós somos o nosso próprio parceiro
nós temos pelas regras do nosso controle
ou em nós
os fármacos podem ajudar mas já muito
nós podemos fazer usando a nossa própria
mente mãe de zapata e facto está provado
cientificamente pelo efeito que será
extremamente doloroso
se a pessoa acreditar e portanto
acreditar aqui é palavra chave e prefere
que a mensagem eu queria passar aqui é
um grande desafio para as neurociências
deus o neurocientista trazer é realmente
o conhecimento pé a utilidade do chamado
a exata portanto a grande questão é a
atenção as metas nós temos que assumir
estas redes são nossas
espero fazer isto acreditando em nós e
não usando forma que eu sou médico e não
usando farhot e seria extraordinário e
aquilo que eu gostaria dizer é que com
mais autoconhecimento nós tiveram sob o
nosso controle mas 12 tipos de câncer em
relação à vida e à mera para peixe
pessoais clínicas pizzaria podemos
ganhar ou não temos força suficiente
para assegurar que ele sugerisse pensões
por exemplo como o jogo com possível o
jogo patológico é que é uma situação
clínica parece também doenças pessoa nem
tarde espera-se para atenção à pessoa
sabe perfeitamente racionalmente e não
deve jogar está estourado uma fortuna
e todavia continuou a jogar tem um
impulso desligado
temos aqui duas forças nada nos desviam
cosmos naquilo naquela fração de segundo
em que a pessoa vou não vou só decidirá
falhou organismo decisão é que temos
aqui duas forças
uma força que é automática que o impulso
teixeira e o control está a família ea
mulher muita volta destas duas forças
o controlo falha e o impulso automático
já que vai encarar nossos e lages também
é o autoconhecimento
vamos dar um executivo mais comentados
da imagem ea chuteira dormia e ainda da
pessoa poupada que se poupará os dados
para apresentou o jogo a vontade de
jogar tudo tiver atar e os chapéus
coppio tributários coppio significa
decisões na área da saúde ou seja é
imagine a pessoa tenha complicado havia
aberto em fazer a decisões sobre a sua
saúde novamente o desafio contra o eu
não vou andar a injetar insulina assim
vez podia estar certa que vida e 20 anos
decisão de descontar gem o tempo e
portanto são estas decisões têm uma nova
mp pertencem à pessoa com a estudante e
o que é muito curioso é que é essa
característica de decisão na área da
saúde as versões diferentes na área
financeira e isso também é muito curioso
observar aqui é macho o quadro já goga
percebe uma pessoa que senta e alcance
mas perdeu o controle da nave central da
igreja já não sei traseira e muitas
vezes que estas ofertas perderam o
controle sobre a capacidade de ter
prazer e portanto voltamos a esta
economia control e decisão
e então sim é verdade sobre o nosso
controle cognitivo está entre as duas
variáveis como é que nossa entre e agora
vamos dar alguns exemplos a nossa
investigação
como é que nós podemos tratar isso como
é que deve tratar uma pessoa ser mais
controlada vai dar um exemplo
a neurose obsessiva compulsiva o senhor
vai verificar dez vezes jogadas
a segunda já está com é preciso
verificar racional mesmo mas vai lá
mesmo tem o mesmo impulso automático com
foco nos dois lados da moeda controlo e
impulso irracional e então pensei nas
folias uma forma frequente tratar as
conheço as janelinhas presente com as
cobras é a exposição a pessoa aprenda a
ter controle sobre estilo e portanto o
tratamento das ruas muitas vezes passa
exposição e portanto nós decidimos
aproveitar este momento explicação não
diria controversa mas é ela e somente
nós fomos os doentes poderosa possível
possível aos seus medos e os envia hoje
aprendem a ter autoconhecimento sobre o
que está em jogo é o servo de deus eu
vou poupar os detalhes técnicos mas aqui
vêm luvas ou sair da caixinha
luvas foram usadas por outra pessoa ea
criar direita luvas serão no bloco
operatório é evidente
o curso tem horror a contaminação está
uma exposição violeta nós vovô voltou a
fixar em entrevistas com psicólogos
clínicos cometem os doentes e tentar os
esposos uma prova certa forma
terapêutica não grávida através de que a
reunião foi um dia que tenta curar as
pessoas mas também para tentar perceber
como é que está a falhar mas isso vai
sempre o controle do impulso
fizemos muitas coisas a pessoas que não
tenham favor a contaminação a de
arrumação dos quartos que eu venho
ensina e o que as encontradas no cérebro
encontramos estes dois lados da moeda
isso a viagem destaque especial joão
paulo cunha também já participou
salvei o ano passado aqui neste dex e
que tenha neste estudo de imagens e
funcional pessoas ficam dentro de um
tomógrafo estímulos às vezes contou com
meu para correção do joão paulo cunha
isso é o que nós chamamos preocupação de
sintomas tem que ser uma coisa muito
controlado o que nós vimos alguma zona
converteu os dois já ninhos muita moral
jovem à esquerda na imagem em cima é uma
zona que está interativa é uma zona do
cérebro responsável por comportamentos
automáticos que a pessoa não consegue
pará e nós vimos uma zona muito vermelha
mas também vemos chegarem aqui embaixo
daqueles que naquela vem aquela mancha
azul no quadro faz a uma zona azul
significa uma zona que está menos ativa
é exatamente uma zona que tem a ver com
o controlo o objetivo ou seja a pessoa
pode ser muito ingênuo como é muito
frequente generosa que se for possível
para ter toda a racionalidade mas
naquele instante o cérebro controla
apagado e ossel observa que domina o
cérebro automático e racional e eu sou
investigador e já estivesse do outro
também todos têm um pouco e exprime
também foi na missão é um princípio que
nós queremos não é nós temos duas forças
do nosso cérebro uma pedra final e outra
quem esteja em curso vai acontecer elas
ou fazer esperados e saber isso é uma
coisa que ajuda e e em algum aspecto
interessante deste estudo
pensando na frente vou entrar na parte
mais perigosa delas
acho que se competir psicopatia fugir
também muito ligado ao controle nós hoje
porque poderia que psicopata tem marcas
ganhará era o que eu escolher poderia
estar sozinhos longe do planeta terra e
mar
vou explicar porque a nossa imagem
tradicional psicopata ela vai atrás das
grades é alguém muito frio muito grande
ao stress
podemos transformar o primeiro jogo é
transformada de negativa ou positiva e
outra é o comportamento desinibido
impossível comportamentos inapropriados
mas também pode ser algo que pode ser
importante quando é preciso enfrentar
uma determinada situação e portanto é é
a psicopatia ao começar a ser visto de
outra forma de pergunta pelos faz há
muitos artigos e até de fora sem livros
crise em espanha a maior parte dos
psicopatas não só na prisão é assunto
que outra coleta foi uma das profissões
em que há mais que se for para ficar
esperando vou acreditar na política e no
e empresas
com isso não mexe faça é hoje a agenda é
uma decisão que terá os dias fome mas
vem aliás perdeu a grécia os interessado
cobras fato e gravata e astutos e isso
não era um dos que realmente mostram um
psicopata tem um tipo de controle ocorre
manipuladora frieza pouco impacto e isso
é uma construção muito curiosa control e
e completamente impossível psicopata em
mato em importantes e frio é importante
é importante e um pouco
um soldado seria uma coisa encontrou
para enfrentar as estrelas que é isso
também é uma grande empresa vive uma
certa frieza e talvez por isso algum não
vou dizer que são todos mas alguns
políticos e alguns diretores de empresas
realmente tem essas características
usando critérios podem ser mais ou menos
de tiras a um outro tipo de nos tornamos
um pouco entre povos
quando fazemos este tipo de estudos é
uma doença e os cuidados e agora vou
pensar próprio aproxima
o lado o autismo este é um exemplo são
crianças que chegou a o tratamento de
infecção e que nos parecem diferentes
não se parecem melhores nem piores são
diferentes
vocês vejam aí opinó os crimes vêm
equipes diferentes de as crianças
normais fazem perfeitamente bem o
segundo da direita não consegue integrar
o pico a não consegue entregar
integraram no cálculo global vocês
conseguem ver é muito difícil juntar ao
mesmo tempo os pés gil jardim surgem os
antis completamente organizados vêem o
mundo uma forma diferente e nós temos
que receber para nós é uma grande missão
que nos leva a tentar perceber o outro
então como é que nós vamos tentar a
tratar ou reabilitar a expectiva função
colocamos estas crianças em mundos
virtuais é a tecnologia que estamos a
desenvolver a criança já havia de
unidade pólo em que o mundo é mais tão
grave e elas pois tentam transferir
ilhas num produto real portanto sabe
lidar com uma tecnologia da próxima
semana reúne data pois elas sintam mais
confortáveis por galina a estréia nessa
psicóloga
os convites para a imprensa baiana ao
longo do tempo para pensar pra frente
jonas remédios são as zonas onde a
pessoa imagina uma espécie de mapa de
cores
estas crianças olham para pessoa já tem
projetos em uma outra cara não aprovaram
ontem em três outras pessoas
nós tentamos fazer é que ela se recupera
e assim 13 o corpo porque isso é muito
importante para o controle da interação
social
fazemos estas crianças interagir num
virtual crianças e adultos em que o
avatar é mais gravar e então vou falar
não para entrarem é o tal projecto
europeu nós temos e tem muito a ver com
mais a nós ensinamos pessoa é modular a
sua vida
tal você diz isso é impossível sim pedir
emprego um dar um evento em cada dia eu
não consigo o documento ainda não
consegui mas é mais fácil mudar a minha
vida mental porque eu imagino e ao mesmo
tempo é ver o diário observa o mundo não
com essa imaginação
então vamos mostrar um exemplo pelo fim
de um vídeo em que governava tap que a
pessoa participa nos preços e vai tentar
fazer sujeira que é importante o pior
mês dos outros também temos que saber
produzir isto é uma coisa é a
universalidade é outra primeira eu
precisei ele primeiro precisa de
primeiro e então vamos ver nesta neste
vídeo aqui embaixo da linha branca ea
vida do jornal e quando ela só mais apto
avatar sorrir e portanto é isto é um
projecto está em curso um projecto
europeu co tem alguém que nós estamos a
tentar ensinar as pessoas no ano a
atividade mental é prestar atenção a
expressão a emoção e os próprios
manipularem essa expressão avatar e com
isso começam a perceber o que é
impossível idade a expressão e portanto
nós temos um projeto mais rápido e por
isso é que eu tô tão contente de estar
aqui para enviar o projeto com o bolso
obrigado por nossa atenção